[Musique]
ils sont nombreux cette année à demander
de l'aide alimentaire au niveau de
l'anus inchangé plus de travail c'est le
chef cuisinier quand tout le monde est
passé par la passé la soirée chez un ami
sylvain desjardins lui a proposé d'aller
chercher un penny de noël va limiter de
façon si je mesure un imageur pour lui
il fallait quelqu'un qui est l industrie
ce que fait le resto plateau offre des
repas tous les midis et les nouveaux
clients augmente à peu près 50 % de
notre clientèle régulière puis 50% d'une
clientèle que qu'on n'avait pas avant
depuis le début de la pandémie 22 % des
québécois ont dû faire des compromis sur
leur alimentation par manque d'argent
les sécurité alimentaire a donc doublé
depuis le mois de mars pour faire un
ordre de grandeur c'est presque un point
8 millions de la population et est la
suivante % d'insécurité grève jeu c'est
extrêmement préoccupant alors la banque
alimentaire racines croisé près par 180
panier chaque semaine les jeunes
familles et les étudiants se font plus
nombreux l'image de la banque
alimentaire c'est plus la même image
aujourd'hui on ne colle pas ça la
pauvreté en coltan à une situation
ponctuelle qui est là et que nous devons
nous soutenir nous tous la période des
fêtes pourrait s'avérer plus difficile
pour de nombreuses familles cette année
alors que les traditionnels collègues du
russe ont annulé les organismes espèrent
recevoir de l'aide grâce aux dons faits
en ligne et dans les épiceries ici marc
isabelle roche radio canada montréal